so I know that a lot of you are probably
thinking to yourselves I thought we
wanted the Beyonder I want to bring you
guys the Beyonder don't worry like we're
going to talk about the secret war
secret Wars or I guess secret Wars one
super worse - and the Illuminati retcon
Beyonder what we have to do here is we
have to kind of backpedal a little bit
now for those of you guys who are
keeping up with time runs out those of
you guys who are reading new Avengers
and saw New Avengers number 29 when Hank
Pym comes back and says I brought the
beyonders this conversation is going to
be extremely important to you but kind
of a fun fact here that's the first time
we've ever seen what the beyonders look
like we've never actually seen their
physical form before and there's a
reason for that kicking this whole thing
off I guess just kind of jumping into it
what we do here is we pick up with
Fantastic Four issue number 319 now what
this does is give us an explanation on
what the beyonders are and what they do
keeping in mind here that we don't know
what they look like
what's explained to us here is that
somewhere along the line the Beyonder
should come into existence and some kind
of a Dark Dimension now because this
dimension has no light I would go as far
as to say there has no galaxies or
anything because as we know here in the
real world
galaxies reflect light planets reflect
light moons so on and so forth even the
universe itself it's putting off some
measure of light and so with there being
no light whatsoever in that universe
chances are there there is nothing
forward to reflect light off of the
Beyonder simply just kind of exists in
that reality but what we know here is
that again when they came into existence
for some reason or another they became
interested in the earth-616 continuity
now this is expanded on further when we
learn that they beyonders because they
never actually leave their native
dimension had employed a
extraterrestrial race an alien race and
the earth-616 continuity called the new
wall-e
now the new wall-e were paid by the
beyonders and is to say they were paid
in gold and the whole purpose of the new
wall-e being paid by the V honors was
for the new wall-e to come to the come
to the planet Earth and to effectively
create the Savage Land the Savage Land
as those of you guys know who V the read
the comics or even saw x-men the
animated series is a place in Antarctica
where you have a mishmash of ecosystems
that are coinciding together you have
people living with Dinosaurs you have
technology so on and so forth this is
the entire basis for this the beyonders
wanted to study the concept of evolution
they want to study why it is and how
things evolved from one thing to the
next because presumably they were just
endowed with some kind of power again we
don't really know that and so what the
new oli did is they spent around ten
maybe fifteen thousand years going
through the process of basically
curating this giant I guess eco system
taking all different kinds of alien life
I'm sorry all different kinds of life
over that's over time from the planet
Earth and throwing it all onto this
location into the Savage Land and so
what happened is that following their
knowledge of evolution after studying
the Savage Land
for some reason or another again we
don't really know here the beyonders and
the new oli parted ways and so what the
beyonders did is they created a group
called the Fortis schemes
now the Fortis schemes were designed
specifically to follow the orders of the
beyonders but what they had also done is
any creative the forest schemes for the
purpose of basically analyzing why
people exist why aliens exist what's the
purpose of life and the universe and the
earth 6-1-6 continuity because again for
reasons that aren't explained to us
they've become particularly interested
in this continuity and so what the
Fortis Kean's report back to the
beyonders of is that basically we exist
to attain the things we don't have
that's what drives us
for some people it's money for some
people it's a life mate for some people
it's power that really just kind of
depends on the life experiences and what
makes that character or alien who they
are and so as a result the Beyonder said
rationalize that if sentient life exists
on and the earth-616 continuity if it
exists to attain the things that doesn't
have then perhaps it can move to the
next stage of its evolution and
eventually reach the kind of omnipotence
of the honors have reached if they were
given a tool to do so and so what the
beyonders did is they went to the
negative zone and inside the negative
zone they began placing these various
little packets of energy that could be
accessed here now this is very important
here because this will lead into the
whole creation of the Beyonder with
these little packets
I guess these little pieces of energy
around the negative zone what would
happen is that a portal could be open to
the negative zone and the energy could
be siphoned out or the energy would be
exposed from here the energy could begin
to be contained inside of some kind of a
I guess a casing of sorts and thus it
would become the Cosmic Cube this is how
cosmic use came into existence now again
the Cosmic Cube added exists in the air
6-1-6 continuity
doesn't exist the same way as it does on
other continuities but the fact remains
this is how the energy is gained think
of it as if you were getting water into
a water balloon the water being the
energy from the negative zone and the
balloon being the I guess the casing
that would become the Cosmic Cube as a
balloon fills up with water the balloon
becomes something that you can use it
becomes an effective tool the purpose
behind this was again for basically
sentient life to use the Cosmic Cube be
granted selfish desires to achieve
whatever it wanted to achieve and so
what had happened was that when Owen
Reese when molecule man had gained his
powers when he had his I guess is
electromagnetic incident he had torn
open a hole torn open a portal to this
excess energy that had been left by the
beyonders but rather than the portal
being able to find a place for it to go
to rather than finding a casing the
portal did or I guess the energy to two
things the first thing that I guess the
first thing that happened is that part
of the energy traveled into Owen Reese
making him the molecule man making him
one of the most powerful beings to ever
exist in the history of Marvel Comics
and probably a character whose power
exceeds the one or I'm sorry exceeds the
Living Tribunal if we're talking about
pre-read Khan which we're not going to
get into but the other I guess the rest
of the energy just kind of festered and
developed and gained sentience and when
it did it became the Beyonder now the
Beyonder began to question it began to
analyze humanity analyze the planet
earth as well as life throughout the
entire earth-616 cosmos and so what it
did is it wanted to study the concept of
good and evil why do people fight each
other what's the entire basis here and
so what it did is it took various
superheroes of supervillains from across
the entire Marvel continuity the entire
Marvel landscape and it threw them onto
two separate vessels now in truth this
was basically an entire concept whereby
Marvel had taken the most prominent
members and so we saw Galactus we saw
Ultron Doctor Doom various characters
who existed throughout the year six one
six continuity who were well known there
was really no reason to include
extremely obscure characters because
fans wouldn't know who they were and so
once once the Beyonder had created
battleworld once he created this
mishmash of different planets they were
combined into a single planet he put
them all down there and said they can
fight and whoever it is that wins will
kiss they will get their heart's desire
one of the most infamous phrases of the
Beyonder from here once the actual
secret wars
comes to an end then we pick up with
Secret Wars too and this is when the
Beyonder appears that people most
commonly think of it is to say the guy
wearing the all-white suit with a curly
gray or curly black hair now initially
he doesn't appear that way when he
appears to Owen Reese he appears as a
mishmash kind of a patchwork of various
characters that he had seen and the
during the Secret Wars event he has kind
of the I guess the logo of the Fantastic
Four on his chest he has a little bit of
the champion in him he has just
different forms of characters and his
entire purpose as he's here at least as
far as he explains to Owen Reese is that
he's here to understand now the best way
to think of the Beyonder here is as a
newborn baby he just doesn't understand
anything he doesn't understand anything
about why we do what we do and that's
his purpose why do people get up and
brush their teeth in the morning why
don't we go to work why do we pay for
things with money why do all these
different things happen why do people do
drugs these are the kind of things the
Beyonder seek to learn this is what he
wanted to understand but the real cool
experiences that come across with the
Beyonder are when he comes across
various a criminals different elements
of things like that and one of the
really interesting scenes here is when
he comes across a woman of the night and
ultimately he's more or less I guess put
into a circumstance where he's with
various other women and I guess like all
right like the Beyonder has sex with
hookers there I said it
like that's what happens I don't know
how else to say it but that's basically
what happens he's undergoing all these
experiences you're undergoing all this
whole process of learning things but the
fact remains that the Beyonder in terms
of secret Wars - moves from this
omnipotent kind of character in secret
wars one to becoming this character
that's learning about life learning
about things understanding how things
progress again much in the same way that
we do ask people now what this leads us
into is the Brian Michael Bendis retcon
of the entire beyonder and the reason
why is because what we had found was
that this was just kind of an open-ended
thing that Secret Wars - came to an end
there were some pitches and I guess some
patches here and there where the
Beyonder appeared in different stories
and he was mentioned from time to time
and things like that but it was never
really a closed-off thing it was never
really here's how the entire situation
ends
what happens is that Brian Michael
Bendis guest says that during the
initial conflict of Secret Wars the
Charles Xavier had read the mind of the
Beyonder and that when he dated Charles
Xavier had learned that the Beyonder is
a combination of human I'm sorry OVA in
human and mutant making him an inhuman
mutant that he was born in in human but
that he has a mutant gene and so when he
underwent exposure to the Terrigen mists
it granted him hither to unjust
unfathomable powers now in truth a lot
of comic book fans were very mad about
this they were very angry about this
because this did two things the first
thing it did is it took away the
ambiance of the Beyonder it took away
the idea of this character the Beyonder
the second thing it did was that it made
the Beyonder someone who could be
defeated the greatest aspect of the ond
of the greatest element of the Beyonder
was that he is from the beyond verse he
is from a universe that exists outside
the entire Marvel multiverse that all
things change that all things are
totally different that he is the
amalgamation of all sentience for him
things just are they're just they're
like he's just it like there's nothing
to understand there's nothing to learn
there's nothing to experience people
loved the idea of watching a character
grow and expand and try different things
with Brian Michael Bendis coming back
and saying nope he's a mutant in human
hybrid it takes away from this effect
but again this is just one of those
things where sort of personal preference
there are some people that love this
concept that love the idea of an inhuman
that has a mutant gene the question
being what happens when they undergo
exposure to the Terrigen mists these are
things that again it's really just kind
of left up to personal preference with
that being said we're going to head and
bring this video to an end hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace
be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly but we had one more important
sound we wanted you to hear
[Music]